♪♪
Narrator: THERE ARE MORE
THAN 600,000 BRIDGES
CONNECTING ROADS ACROSS THE USA.
BUT OVER 65,000 OF THEM
ARE STRUCTURALLY FAULTY
AND NEED TO COME DOWN.
WHEN THEY DO COME DOWN,
EVERY OUNCE OF STEEL
CAN BE RECLAIMED
AND RE-ENGINEERED.
AND SOME OF THAT TWISTED METAL
WILL BE SPINNING
A BRAND NEW SOUND.
THE BRIDGE'S STRUCTURAL STEEL
WILL GET AN EXTENDED PLAY
AS A HEAVYWEIGHT
CAST-IRON TURNTABLE.
Narrator:
IN VIRGINIA, METALWORKERS
SHEAR AND MELT BRIDGE PARTS
AND BRAKE ROTORS.
ALL THAT'S LEFT IS A FURNACE
FULL OF MOLTEN CAST IRON.
THE FIRST STEP
IN CREATING THE TURNTABLE
IS TO MAKE THE BASE.
A FOUNDRY WORKER ROLLS
A SAND MOLD INTO PLACE.
SAND MOLDS ARE HELD TOGETHER
AND HARDENED WITH RESIN.
AT 3,000 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT,
THE METAL IS READY
TO BE POURED INTO THE MOLDS.
A FOUNDRY WORKER SWINGS
A LADLE OVER AND HAND-POURS
THE CAST IRON INTO THE MOLDS.
THE HOT METAL FILLS A CAVITY
INSIDE THE MOLD,
FORMING THE SHAPE
OF THE TURNTABLE BASE.
IT HARDENS FOR 15 MINUTES
BUT IS STILL NOT COOL.
A WORKER ROLLS THE MOLD
OFF THE END
OF THE CONVEYER BELT.
WHEN IT HITS THE FLOOR,
THE MOLD BREAKS,
AND THE RESIN AND THE SAND
BURST INTO FLAMES.
A FRONT LOADER SCOOPS UP
THE RED-HOT BASE
AND SETS IT ASIDE
TO COOL IN SAND.
A WORKER FERRIES THE BASE
TO A SHOT BLAST TUMBLER,
A MACHINE THAT SCRAPES AWAY
THE CAST IRON'S ROUGH TOP LAYER.
AN ELECTROMAGNET
LIFTS THE CAST IRON BASE
ONTO A COMPUTER-CONTROLLED
CUTTING MACHINE.
THE MACHINE MILLS HOLES
TO ACCOMMODATE
THE TURNTABLE'S COMPONENTS
AND WIRING.
NEXT, A MACHINIST MILLS
A 35-POUND BRASS PLATTER.
NOW THE COMPONENTS
ARE READY FOR ASSEMBLY.
HE PLACES THE BRASS PLATTER
ON A SPINDLE
AND ATTACHES A BELT.
THE BELT DRIVES THE PLATTER
AND CONTROLS THE SPEED.
THEN THE TECHNICIAN DYNAMICALLY
BALANCES THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
TO FINISH THE ASSEMBLY,
HE ADDS THE TONE ARM
AND THE STYLUS.